is here eric hanson he makes his first
move i'm not even sure if jordan is
there yet oh he is here we go he must be
there and uh it's no more kara khan he
used the karakanashi to defeat eric
earlier uh earlier today but it's the
berlin defense rock solid one of the
most solid openings in chess so jordan
only needing a draw he's trying to lock
things down and this is exactly what
anishi giri did against hansen yesterday
when anish only needed a draw
so uh jordan taking a leaf out of his
dutchman's playbook his fellow
dutchman's playbook there yeah but
that game was quite interesting actually
because um
eric had a golden opportunity to strike
back
and he didn't he missed
he missed the shot and
well now we're going to see how this
develops what do you think berlin good
choice uh for jordan it's not his style
so i'm very surprised he's gone for that
jordan is much more creative the berlin
is kind of one where you're just trying
to lock things down and
eric has actually chosen a different
strategy to the game against denise
yesterday he traded off a bishop for a
night which means we get a slower game
here eric just pushing a pawn forward uh
white has the better pawn structure but
black does have the bishop pair so white
normally just tries to close the center
and slowly maneuver around
it makes a lot of sense it must win
situations just to keep the tension to
not clarify things too quickly eric had
a chance as you mentioned yesterday
ivanka against anish but things kind of
raced
very quickly towards that draw and he
just never managed to get the
opportunity to kind of stamp his
authority on it and at least today
this game it's not going to be a quick
one it's uh going to be a lot of tension
left and eric there offering a trade of
bishops trying to get rid of black's
bishop
um yeah it's too early to say maybe but
i think
eric's opening choice is a pretty decent
one in a must-win situation
uh yeah especially against the berlin
there's not much you can do to keep life
left so this is one of the better
options there
play d4 and move one d4 move one is a
good one as well but uh
it's not eric's style he's been on an e4
playing his whole life i i kind of like
what he's done because taking on as you
say c6 you if you if you need to win you
need to unbalance the position and at
least by changing the structure uh it
gives him gives them those chances um
it's quite funny in the position there i
was wondering if if eric had castled
would jordan have pushed the g pawn that
would have been a very interesting push
but i expect eric will go queen side
here um i i i don't know but um he maybe
should again look for ways to mix it up
a bit more if he can yeah it's a bit of
a waiting game with the kings right
because if white commits too early as
you mentioned then black will attack
that side if black commits too early
white has the option of attacking that
side as well and that's actually how
eric lost the first game of today
against jordan he castled too soon and
walked straight into a porn storm uh
jordan threw all the pawns towards his
king
and he's not gonna make the same mistake
twice
and uh talking about waiting game only
two games in my database and it's
telling me you are spot on david once
again white said two moves have been
played have actually been waiting moves
with
both knights so one night has moved to
the square in front of the king getting
ready for potentially some king side
maneuvers and
the other knight has also relocated
itself to the square in front of the
queen getting ready for some action on
the left side of the board yeah so we're
expecting maybe one of the white knights
to move he could make an argument maybe
for the white queen to move as well just
to kind of keep your opponent guessing
if the white queen steps up the board
then white does have those two options
castling either side of the board i
guess the problem simon is no matter
which side white castles there's a
potential kind of avalanche of pawns uh
if white castles that way then there
might be pawns running down and likewise
if you cast on the king side yes maybe
this idea just maneuvering your pieces
to the best square as you can makes a
lot of sense i mean i quite like um
well well i mean i really okay if jordan
doesn't play g5 here i um do you wanna
bet uh no no no
okay okay we're seeing his screen and
hopefully we can stay on this picture
because we're expecting jordan to pick
up a pawn over on the left half of his
screen but the g pawn and push it
forward two squares i said he wouldn't
make the same mistake twice eric but
this is really playing with fire
don't try this at home don't allow your
punch to throw pawns towards your king
and
this is so well known and uh i mean the
reason why the poor move that you guys
are mentioning is so dangerous is
because white has actually picked up
harry and moved it one square
and this means that the contact points
between enemy point pawns is actually
going to be on the fourth row which is
an easier road for black to get to
oh so dangerous i agree i mean there's a
rule in okay
yeah i mean david you can you know you
should have taken it again like the
world champs i think but uh too good at
the better simon i'm never trusting
myself and i think that move will come
it's just not yet yeah and uh okay first
jordan took a moment to solidify the
center to stop white uh pushing any
pawns forward there and now he's brought
his bishop out and look at how jordan
he's not committing his king uh white's
now kind of put his target out there he
said okay my king is on the king side
you go for it if you want to but it
might take you a while to build up that
attack and uh jordan meanwhile is saying
yes i will build up that attack but
first i'm going to keep you guessing
and uh okay it looks like
i mean berlin has a very uh boring
reputation
um maybe a little bit unjustified and i
i normally don't say that but i mean it
was gary kasparov who said uh even the
queenless ending was very interesting to
play but when you see positions like
this they they often in the moodle game
come really to life
with porn storms with attacks against
opponents king which is uh which is good
to see um
and there's a lot of play left here
which i guess is good for eric at the
moment still not entirely sure what what
his his plan will be is he gonna is he
gonna move the pawn
freddy two squares is that something you
do here i'm not sure maybe not here but
at some point yeah white's f pawn could
go forward just as you say it simon yes
it has happened so offering a trade of
pawns so just before i think jordan got
a chance to push forward and start
attacking him uh eric has taken the
opportunity to trade a set of pawns
traded a set of bishops and uh i'm
expecting jordan yeah look at this he's
about to castle on the long side to the
queen side
he's got a choice of either side to
castle and there we go he is an
aggressive player yay yeah good feeling
we did we said yesterday the best way to
get a draw is to play for a win
and i think that that move is uh well
we'll find out if it's a good choice or
not and that's i mean we were talking
about the berlin defense it's the most
drawish opening in chess but no matter
what opening you choose uh at any level
you can put your own spin on it right
you can play a drawish opening for a win
or you can play a really aggressive
opening for a draw so uh yeah jordan
embracing his inner kind of uh his inner
instincts there and just saying okay i'm
going to go for the win i'm going to
castle on the opposite side as you
and uh okay there we go eric just i
don't like that move i got to say just a
very slow po yeah
yeah i'm just like suddenly i'm looking
at it and i'm like hang on a second
if the queen can magically hop over the
bishop
she could plant herself
on the e5 square and attack the knight
and the rook
is there any kind of is there a tactic
yeah i mean there's something on the
dark squares probably not but yeah just
to show the idea uh this bishop if it if
it wasn't in the way then the black
queen for example let's make a random
move it could create a double attack
hitting the knight and hitting the rook
at the same time loose loose pieces do
drop off and uh simon yeah you mentioned
that this is very tempting bishop takes
pawn for example i don't think it quite
works here because you can just bring
the knight back and defend your rook but
yeah yeah he's played he's played it
yeah he's going for it he's played and
moving forwards there we go gary the g
pawn steps forward this time hitting the
white rook and when the white rook
retreats
i mean he can pretty much pre-move this
he's going to push his pawn forward and
this is the one the idea ivanka
mentioned this point is a hook as we
call it you can kind of break open lines
for your attack by using this pawn and
when there's tension between pawns it's
nearly guaranteed that a line will open
up and uh for example if white ever
dreams of taking this pawn which he
shouldn't then suddenly this rook is
open for the black rooks the black queen
is already threatening to sneak in
sometimes and deliver a nasty checkmate
this white king is so open
i mean from the lines but also from the
diagonals and i think eric's in big big
trouble right now um so okay he actually
retreated to a different square this
square but the same idea is happening
this pawn push is going to devastate the
white king and its shelter oh yeah very
dramatic for eric
[Music]
yeah
did these moves like you pointed out
that the hook as you call it
very important i mean when you castle
you have to be so careful
moving pawns in front your king you
often do it to give an escape square for
a back rank but i remember there was a
story about bobby fischer and he lost
the game by playing such a move early on
and he couldn't sleep apparently for
ages just about this little pawn move
which doesn't seem to make much
difference but it's a major target and
look at black's pieces now whose king is
safest is clearly the black king and
that's the most important thing
in such situations but it's it's getting
a little bit murky here i mean okay
black's just going for checkmate
one track mind here jordan uh he's
attacked the white queen with his knight
and when the queen moves i'm pretty sure
his idea is to actually jump forward
with his queen i don't think it actually
works right now uh attack trying to
threaten checkmate this white king has
no escape squares but if you just
shuffle the white rook forward one
square suddenly whoops there's a pin on
this diagonal and it's only one check
it's only one check and suddenly after
for example a queen trade look at this
black knight it is trapped so jordan
this was his plan but he can't quite
break through to checkmate so he has to
go for a backup and in this position
maybe he just just needs to give this
nice support maybe with his rook maybe
by bringing his queen forward uh maybe
even pushing harry the h pawn that was
the move there
to me actually push harry and open up
those lines
i also quite like i was thinking about
bishop takes pawn as well just to
cover the uh square that the rook wants
to go to maybe this was slightly
premature though i mean uh you didn't
need to rush the attack i mean i love
rushing the attack if it works but um
you're giving eric some chance now to
bring the queen fours two squares to
consolidate uh to maybe start kicking
some of the black pieces away and the
danger here uh for jordan is if he
overdoes it you can easily get too
excited move in move that queen and as
you pointed out david and suddenly
realize i'm not checkmating i i've
done a bit of premature uh attack
yeah
and actually this would be a losing
blunder uh it looks like you're
threatening checkmate but you lose
because your knight is trapped so jordan
is still doing well but suddenly the
stakes are higher and the margin for
error all right well
he's going for age five he's trying to
open up more lines trying to open up
this rook to break through to the white
king and eric has to shut that down he
attacks the black knight
all right eric hansen he is fighting for
his life he has to win this game to have
any hopes of uh surviving this match
these are the results uh so far on day
two of the oslo esports cup magnus
carlsen is down by one point against
liam lee losing the first game they are
now playing game three magnus with the
white pieces fighting for a win in that
game and uh pragnanda he won the first
game against chakri and mama jarov and
is in the lead in that match they are
also now playing game three and uh of
course uh so is anish giri and uh young
christoph duda two draws between
those two so they are tied
now playing game three but uh it's most
dramatic for eric hanson losing two
games he has to win this game but it's
not looking good for him
it's not looking good at all and black's
knight we mentioned it did need support
and it's been supported by a black pawn
so
no opening up of the lines for the black
rook yet towards the white king but the
black knight on a nice outpost and
still that white pawn on g4 that ivanka
mentioned it's up for grabs next move
black's bishop is about to pounce and
capture it black's rooks are going to
start lining up towards the white king
and
if we just think about the grand scheme
of things everything's happening on the
king side black's king
never in any trouble i mean it's going
to take white five six moves to even
have a serious threat against the black
king and he's not going to get that time
not going to get that luxury so
yeah it's looking very one-sided traffic
right now unfortunately for eric i was
gonna say you know the boss evaluation
i'm misreading it looks looks like it's
uh in favor of white but you know the
position is quite treacherous or if it's
on the black side it's a black side okay
yeah it looks like uh black has a plus
one advantage right now plus 1.3 i mean
i was thinking of some drastic moves
here like moving the rook two squares
forwards um just to try to get the
queens off just to try to block things
off but maybe maybe a better version of
that is moving the knight into the
center
i if i'm white here i really want to
swap the queens off because i i know i'm
going to get checkmated if i don't do
something drastic and understanding the
change of pace in a game of chess is
really important that you have to do
something otherwise you're just going to
lose and
this is the situation i think eric's in
if he doesn't do anything drastic he
will just get checkmated so hence why
move such as this is kind of logical i
feel yeah it looks good simon i agree
with this uh with this kind of
suggestion because here if the queens do
disappear for example even if black ends
up winning the pawn back and suddenly no
more checkmate threats against the white
king suddenly whites rooks actually may
be superior to black's open file and
some pressure some targets
so if this happens i don't think black
should get tempted to trade pieces black
needs to keep his on the board keep the
ammunition for your attack later on and
maybe moving the queen and i also like
your other suggestion this one is
complicated black still has ideas such
as taking the spawn i like this one just
from a visual point of view planting the
rock on this square and this is uh
definitely one to remember for viewers
at home sometimes you can break the
trend of your opponent's attacks just by
giving up material and here i'm not
quite sure it changes too much but just
kind of visually just this type of pawn
structure rock solid and
here yes maybe black can continue the
attack by bringing rooks across but in
general giving up material just to
change the nature of the position get
rid of getting rid of your opponent's
best pieces is quite a good
uh good idea to keep in mind so um here
yeah i don't see anything else to be
honest other than this night move you
could make an argument for maybe
retreating the knight to try and remove
black's best attacking piece but it's
just too slow black will suddenly
capture this pawn attack your rook and
you're running out of squares you can
move it up one square but every move
comes with a threat
and it's getting pretty drastic very
scary now you have to have to change the
pace here uh if you're eric and uh give
yourself some chances i mean he probably
doesn't want to swap the queens off but
you must when you're about to get
chipmated and uh it seems like uh that
is a serious danger to his king here
yeah if he doesn't find this move i
think eric's just
doomed over the next few turns yeah oh
okay slow queen move that is not going
to help too much now this pawn can be
captured that's rook can even come
across to take it
oh that feels a bit too slow okay the
black queen moves
very surprised actually jordan didn't
pause before uh playing this move
that's a bad sign actually it just shows
that you're a bit over eager
yeah
because you know he had all the time in
the world to calculate what would happen
after bishop takes porn and maybe there
might be some rook takes pawn but you
know it's good to sit there and
calculate and kind of try to get to the
nuts and bolts of the position just
playing quickly just means it's a little
bit superficial at times and you can
potentially make a mistake
and well eric just
inviting a piece that wasn't working to
the uh the defense wasn't gonna say
party but that's the wrong move
definitely word rather it's definitely
not a party for white this position at
least he's centralized now with his
pieces so any attack that comes he will
have some chance of stopping it and this
is one thing i've noticed from jordan in
the past before uh whenever i play him
i've played him a lot uh in over the
borders and in blitz chess he's a bit
impatient he often gets great positions
against me
but somehow as long as i can stabilize i
know that he gets uh kind of trigger
happy sometimes and he tries to attack
too soon or if it's just a very quiet
position earlier we're talking about the
art of doing nothing when i play jordan
i do nothing and he lashes out he'll do
something sometimes it's great but
sometimes it's
just uh premature and uh he's just not
ready
so okay he's pausing now which is a good
sign he needs to think now
i was just thinking about your book that
you you kind of said you might write
out of doing nothing sounds very eastern
doesn't it very eastern philosophy yeah
the art of zen yeah
all right well that would be quite a
thick book right wouldn't it
the opposite right it should be just the
opposite of one piece
i was going to say the engine here is
really liking it for jordan forest and i
was going to mention that because i just
saw a tweet that
the engine that we are using stockfish
just won the top chess engine
championship setting a new record
winning by 19 points i'm not 100 sure
what that means but i guess the top
engines are up against each other in
chess games
and stockfish won yeah they're often
given a set of positions uh they're
given a variety of different openings
different styles of positions and they
compete against each other they play one
game with white one game with black and
stockfish is just the best one out there
these days it calculates so well and uh
understands everything so great and wow
big moment move on the board i was just
going to say i mean eric's grabbed the
pawn but it's so risky jordan's about to
push harry the h4 inside he's so scary
that move so scary look at what jordan's
done as well he's hovering over the
square he hasn't dropped the pawn but uh
that looks like a good move
one move away from checking the white
king promoting a pawn then
yeah eric's plan i mean eric it's like a
tempo away from doing very well because
he's also about to bring his queen in
take the pull on the left-hand side get
to the black king or this move attack
himself yeah this is really heating up
now
really heating up happening has jordan
just prematurely gone for this attack
because it still looks very good for
black but it's not sided traffic anymore
white is threatening checkmate in one
move look at the white queen and knight
i mean you can look at it on either
board right now but white's queen and
knight are threatening to take the pawn
in front of the black king and that
would be checkmate the pawn on the sea
surface is crazy crazy position now
absolutely crazy not pausing to
calculate he's about to push that pawn
forward stopping checkmate
but he needs to pause they've got 10
minutes really they have 10 minutes in a
very complicated position they're not
using their time properly i mean it has
to be said you've got this position
where one mistake will change the game
uh it's a such complex position just
slow down first of all can you look for
the most forcing moves moving the black
pawn on with check promoting to a knight
well okay
that i love promoting tonight i mean how
many opportunities that's what you look
at first because they're forcing moves
uh so just slow down here that's what
he's done okay for jordan fans that is a
good thing that he's paused and didn't
rush with this porn move because as
simon says uh we'll show it actually on
the board in a moment but uh
there is a very very tempting option
black's h pawn can step towards the
white king checking and after the white
king moves you can't promote to a queen
because you actually lose time and you
will get checkmated but you can promote
maybe the problem is he's on the
computer and he's got auto promoter
queen on and he doesn't know how to turn
it to promote tonight so when he moves
the h pawn down two squares he needs to
get a knight because if he gets a queen
he will fall into checkmate
it could be i mean i've seen this happen
before
in some games where you have to work out
i'm sure this is not the case but if you
have the i mean a lot of people do this
in blitz chess because it's very rare
when you get a pawn to the other end of
the board that you don't get a queen
extremely rare but in this situation
jordan has to get a knight if he goes to
that plan i mean
it's possible
unlikely but possible maybe the arbiter
therefore you know he could ask the
arbiter if that's the case something
like that is
well you have to think about it yeah
i've played on this uh this cool new
chess 24 play zone before and i think
there is a button with settings where
you can change it during the game but
and jordan does have enough time to do
that over seven minutes but he is going
back to the other plan maybe that's on
his mind simon uh he's about to push his
pawn he thinks there's no reason to rush
and uh go for a promotion to try and
promote to a night he's gone yeah he's
stopped the checkmate threat but now
white's knight can go and capture a pawn
for example with a check
suddenly it's really unclear well i mean
suddenly uh it looks like eric's gonna
have the first punt look at what he's
just done simon he clicked on the
settings and the screen changed slightly
maybe he was looking for that button oh
wow so he might be looking for this just
that's away the settings again i mean
can can you get the arbiter here i mean
to because there are arbiters live to uh
to possibly you know ask them how do i
how do i get a night yeah for sure you
can call us
to help you resolve those kind of things
um
i was just thinking though you know it
does eric's attack
looks you know like it could generate
something but is it more than uh sorry
ivanka he's about to put his king on
what i think is a losing square oh uh
he's about to drag it towards the white
knight but i think that loses really and
i think he has to go towards the center
i think he has to step up the board and
because of her check winning the night
at some point yeah i think oh yes
there we go you could just wait it's a
blunder by jordan a big blunder and not
only can white give a check first with
his queen but he can actually give up
his own knight first to blow open the
wow blow up invisible yeah defenses
around the black king huge developments
eric hansen has to win this game and
suddenly it's looking good but jordan he
only made this move because he needs a
draw he thinks that eric is forced to
give check check and make a draw and he
thinks that will guide him through and
win the match but eric has more than
just a draw here we have to check out
whatever yeah we have to show this all
of us on the board because so much has
been happening and it's fascinating
hopefully we can keep an eye on the
players in this position we were talking
about the night promotion that would
have started not by defending against
the checkmate threat as jordan did but
by pushing forward and simon now this
cool move have ah i've got auto promote
to a queen online
see this is the problem we can show what
happens if you get a queen because maybe
this is something you have to think
about when you're playing these events
if you get the queen it's an auto
promote then white check mates
and this is the incredible sort of extra
drama here so you have to get a knight
with check yeah so actually in this
position black has to promote on this
square to a night and the night i can't
even show it because i've got to promote
on
the board but uh yeah this this knight
would actually check the white king and
this would lead to a very good position
for black but look at jordan he suddenly
realized after not going for this after
not pushing his pawn forward uh instead
defending suddenly after a night check
he should have run away whoops played it
but that's played it i think he's played
it great news for chess for our fans
yeah i got to show this simon but he
should have run his this way to the
center but uh instead as you mentioned
great news for chesapeake fans because
suddenly after a queen check this night
is falling this night is dropping to the
queen and rook
and suddenly jordan with his head on his
hands
it's turned over
it's completely 360 now white is winning
why is several pawns up he's also kind
of uh this is jordan it's kind of turned
a little bit crimson did you notice that
like he was in trouble yeah i've done
that before many times
very easy for a ginger to go red i'll
tell you
maybe what jordan missed as well is that
after a check now from the pawn he can
just hide in front of the uh black pawn
and this white king is an e it's a great
blockader
let's go back to the players jordan is
in huge trouble
it's definitely dramatic right now in
the oslo esports arena eric hansen is he
making that comeback that he has to do
in this match and uh same situation for
magnus carlsen the bar is now all the
way over to magnus's side in his third
game against liam he is down by one
point
in that match but in this one
yeah okay magnus is he making a comeback
just like eric hansen
it's drama in the oslo arena right now
and we saw jordan talking to himself a
minute ago
cursing himself just what has he done
well he pointed this out david from
having experience of him i mean that's
where he needs not just a chess coach
but maybe like
a life coach in some respects it's like
yeah he's playing great moves but when
you're winning just slow down as you
said you pointed out and he's run
straight into that error how do he's i
mean how much time has he got he's got
uh
he could have used that time to to at
least get a draw in this game and now
and now we expect eric to win um
and that will take it into another game
and yeah look at jordan the kind of
disappointment on his face the
devastation there and yeah i played him
in the mr dodgy invitational uh last
year and i was able to knock out jordan
from the tournament because he kept
doing the same to me he would build up
these great positions and then one
premature move or
just a bit too much haste forgetting
about the opponent's resources as well
he often forgot about my ideas and
yeah still that's a that's a bit of a
weakness in this game and he puts the
headset down he's not resigning yet but
he knows that he's losing this game
white's knight is just a great defender
now black's knight has gone no way to
break through look at it look at that
though i mean look how upset he is i
mean that is quite dramatic
just his body language there and if he
loses this game it's not just you lose
and you still a draw next game it's a
good position but he's got to get over
that so psychologically again he's going
to be kicking himself and um that is a
big big thing yeah and uh the reason
he's losing is because he's three pawns
down on the position and the attack now
is just too slow white's offering to
trade uh the queens off now eric doing a
good job there if the queens disappear
it's game over yeah
yeah yeah i think he kind of needed that
moment of dem of desperation just look
at him now he's like okay right now i
need to recover now i need to get back
into full focus mode i mean when i've
whenever i'm i'm in that kind of
situation where i've made a massive
blonde i go well if i could make a
blunder so could my opponent so always
fight on
and the queens have come off which is uh
not great news
for jordan's plans and uh now jordan
offering a trade of rooks you mentioned
simon the chess bra fans there's gonna
be a party for them after this game yeah
i mean uh
yeah yeah i mean it's great to see eric
in a game no nothing against uh jordan
who's a fantastic player we have it's
just nice to see another game as well
we're going to get another game out of
this match um meaning eric still needs
to win with the black pieces he's going
to be tough but he's fighting so well in
this game yeah and all white needs to do
here is move his king out of the way
there is a threat to capture the white
knight at the black rook staring down at
the white king but just move the king
out of the way and
yeah i'm just getting over three pawns
down in an end game not much else to say
about it no i i can remember like going
red uh
my worst my worst time this happened to
me i think we've all done it i had
played a horrible mistake i was playing
i fell into stalemate i was a
grandmaster i was leading a tournament i
was two pieces up and i fell into a
stalemate
against the feed a master and it's funny
how the crowd can smell they can smell
blood they're like wolves this
grandmaster they they were there before
i played it and all of a sudden there's
25 people just obviously laughing and
like look at this idiot and they're just
there and it's just oh my words i just
tried to hide in my hands and i was a
beacon of tomato beacon
go away the wolves are there um but yeah
i've he's found the move david and
credit to eric he's played ever since
jordan's blunder he's played perfect
chess just he rebuffed the attack traded
everything off still keeping his through
pawn advantage and look at this just
putting his everything on safe squares
uh it's the last few moves i think of
this game jordan just going through the
motions getting over his disappointment
yeah it's a maybe about to be a
four-point advantage for white
yeah
it's just a lot of pawns and it's gonna
shift momentum right so still a draw
will be enough for you in in uh game
four but making that comeback and
getting that win must be a huge boost
for eric hansen going into game four
yeah it certainly will be a big boost
and uh he will certainly be primed and
ready for game four and uh when it comes
to jordan we also have to think about
him and here is where his the role of
his second
will be super important because uh we
know that his second at the time this
particular tournament is johan sebastian
christiansen and so johan has to be
ready to get to think about what he's
going to say
how he's going to prep uh your jordan is
he going to be like yeah you can do it
game four or is he going to be like um
what
now you know what you have to do or
whether he's going to just be a bit more
realistic or pragmatic that's when you
need someone who knows you really well
because
sometimes you need someone to speak to
you but sometimes you need to be left
alone so it's sort of
what is the right approach you need
someone who's not just a coach but a
good friend yeah in these situations i
think so yeah
yeah and jordan he's still
he's still visibly visibly upset he
needs to really get it out of his mind
now yeah
i don't know what the best uh best
answer is just keep playing the till the
end of the game play till checkmate get
it out of your system at the board or
just quickly go and kind of take a
longer break now before the next round
i'll take a longer break
resign and just just have a break you
know just go to your room and
eat some sushi yeah
four pawns down now it's five pawns
against one
and uh yeah actually just from
experience as well jordan he doesn't
resign very often uh well not not as
early as some players as well i think
mama jarov is one of the earliest
resigners in world chess at least at the
top and jordan may be one of the
kind of slowest resigners as uh as we
say i've seen major resign in positions
where he's just slightly worse
but uh jordan yeah he often plays on
well we do like it when they play it all
the way to checkmate yes we love that
yeah never resign especially when you're
first learning the game or even i mean
all the way up to super grand master
level like these guys why resign do you
think it should be a rule i mean we do
have rules you cannot offer
draws before a certain move should it be
rule you have to play until checkmate i
would love to see that especially on
this tour in rapid chess but
it is a bit harsh on the players if
they're depressed with their positions
yeah
not great for the mental health kind of
sitting there just thinking oh i'm no
hope and i have to sit here for another
45 minutes
all right well this is great news for
eric hanson is he making that comeback
to have the hopes of taking this to
tie breaks magnus carlsen the bar all
the way over to his side as well
trying to make a comeback against liam
lee
the bar is really liking it for magnus
he is down by one point in that match so
win here will mean that they are tied
before game four so drama in that one as
well pragnanda is in the lead in the
match against mom and dad when the bar
is slightly over to prague side in game
three if he wins this game it's going to
be over he's going to decide the match
again after only three games
mamjarov in a little bit of trouble he
needs at least a draw in this game
dudagiri played two draws so far and the
bar is in the middle in game three as
well
we will definitely see a game four in uh
this one yeah jordan i
i i want you to play on to the end on
one hand but on the other hand there are
so many other exciting games magnus
carlsen's position is crazy right now
really so uh
that looks fascinating i mean uh he does
he looks like your type of position in
that case yeah i'm just looking over and
i'm like hello
i mean the game
is over here eric's going to take that
pawn with his knight next move probably
is well that's one way to win one of the
simplest but three points there's plenty
of ways to win this yeah plenty you can
do many many different things but uh
magnus in a must win situation really at
some point with the white pieces well
not actually quite must win but this is
his big opportunity
must not lose the situation that's a
better way of saying it it's actually
funny because in this position eric is
three pawns up and completely winning in
magnus's game he's three pawns down oh
but he's winning wow so uh he's gone all
out for the attack he's uh kind of
channeled his inner dubai of magnus
carson sacrificed three pawns for a
winning attack or even his inner jordan
he's in a yoda we're going to jump
straight into magnus's game when this
one finishes it looks like eric
is winning
is it hard for eric now to sort of guide
it to that win or is this just about
jordan
ah this is talking about jordan just
simply playing out his frustration and
uh eric's body language is pretty
relaxed there he knows he's winning he
can do anything he doesn't need to rush
even he can just slowly bring the white
king
maybe maybe jordan's just thinking how
he can uh dodge the interviewer you know
you know i've seen duder just you know
like a bit like what's it british
bulldog there's this game bit like rugby
where you're playing the playgrounds and
you've got to you know gets the other
side of the pitch and dodge them i want
to you know maybe thinking do i go left
when i get to the interview and then go
right because i really don't want to
speak to anyone after this so i want to
get to my room and there we go and he
just runs off jordan from force he
resigns game three but he is still in
the lead eric hanson making a comeback
he still has to win